they came down out of the star spaces
unto this earth so that they might deal
a grim and heavy judgement upon their
former servants and they went to and fro
upon the earth terrible in their wrath
like unto mighty towers of flame that
walked like men ye and verily was at rid
of old durable be the elder gods in
their wrath in the hour of their coming
hence these words were from the
Necronomicon for the new viewers who are
not yet familiar with the name Cthulhu
then let us take a quickie until the
info about the monster this creature is
one of the first and modern fiction that
encompasses the giant size and strange
appearances which is quite unique in a
way he is the brainchild of HP Lovecraft
and the source of inspiration for many
guys you and giant monsters we see in
movies and games a monster vaguely
anthropoid outlined but with an octopus
like head whose face was a mass of
feelers with a scaly robbery looking
body with prodigious claws on Hine and
four feet and long narrow wings behind
so alright Cthulhu is a member of the
group of cosmic beings called the great
old ones and they are the offsprings of
the near omnipotent entities called the
our gods
these beings apparently exists out of
the normal space-time and although
worshiped by deranged human cults these
beings are generally imprisoned or
restricted in their ability to interact
with most people cause many of them are
located beneath the sea or inside the
earth or in other dimensions and contact
with people is at least until the
hapless person is unwittingly exposed to
them on the other hand there is another
group of near all-powerful entities
called the Elder Gods they have mostly
human-like appearances and they are
benevolent in nature in different parts
of the world such as Egypt Mesoamerica
and the Mediterranean they were
worshipped by ancient humans as gods the
great old ones called these elder gods
as the payloads the and the gods are
said to be the former lots of the great
old ones while some have specific
appearances like for example neurons who
look like Gandalf most of them are
described as terrific towers of flame
they are said to rule in a star glue
though which is
BG's from
today watch the earth eternally although
they will not explain as much by
Lovecraft their mythos spring from the
stories written after the author's death
and in these tales it can be said that
the Elder Gods opposed and often wage
war with the outer God's and the great
old ones so it can be assumed that the
battles were cosmic in nature and often
occurred in strange planets and outer
space there are slight details we can
see about what happened after the war
between the great old ones and the Ella
gods for example they are almost at par
in power with the our gods and our
magnitudes more powerful than the great
old ones in the UH aspre click and
Colton it is said that both the earth
and the Ella gods originated from a
nameless dimension in which they ruled
supreme they created as a thoughts and
uber Sattler as slaves so that they
would in turn create a race of servants
not long after the Elder Gods entered
the universe and installed their power
in beetlejuice they broke into a war
with the great old one standing
victorious and imprisoning them in the
earth or other planets and dimensions
but it has grimly prophesized in the
Necronomicon that the great old ones
shall break free when the cycle return
it and the Elder Gods shall reach war
with them once more but the great old
ones are not as powerless and frail as
they might seem in front of them for
example they were responsible for
killing all of Catherine's family and
this katana was another of the Ella gods
but it is kind of confusing asius also
called the twin brother of Cthulhu one
might wonder as to the possibility of
cosmic beings being admitted into the
ranks of the Ella gods and empowered by
them from beyond this current dimension
as kisana
is the current leader of the faction and
also the brother of Cthulhu despite his
immense power he is not capable of
actual violence and only uses binding
spells or memory erasure to deal with
his enemies katana is supposedly
responsible for the fact that great old
ones fear the elegant sign as he plays a
fear of it in the back of their crew
subconsciousness this brings us to the
fact that this war between the Ella gods
and the great all one's might have not
been as physical
brutal but rather our struggle for
dominance by sheer will and the use of
cosmic magic but also using different
races and armies to battle each other in
what can be called a proxy warfare
several scholars have speculated that
Lovecraft descriptions of both the Elder
Gods and great old ones as one of
anticipating an event equivalent in
judeo-christian mythology when got
through Lucifer and the other rebel
angels out of heaven to reign over hell
in this context being the Elder Gods
banishing Cthulhu and the other great
old ones into the depths of the Pacific
Ocean and other places to lie in a
deathlike slumber for eons but whatever
might be it seems that as being
prophesized in the Necronomicon Cthulhu
ship Negras Nyarlathotep cthugha and the
others with the combined strength of the
our gods on the asset oath shall face
off again with the Elder Gods in a war
that will determine the universe and so
with that we come to the end of the
video about the war of the Elder Gods
and great old ones I know I might have
missed out on quite a lot of things and
maybe and maybe we can discuss more
about this in the comment section so do
you like share and subscribe for more
content on monsters guide you and all
that creature stuff